la msp et un enfant naturel de la
cohabitation
c'est la période où jacques chirac et
martine aubry avait inventé ce système
qui en est quand on est issu qui
passaient d'ailleurs en europe à peu
près partout
quelques années plus tard l'europe toute
entière se défait du mécanisme qui
consiste à donner une assistance sociale
gratuite général aux immigrés
clandestins car c'est le but de m
alors on a essayé de rafistoler à
plusieurs reprises les émeut et
notamment lors du dernier quinquennat
nous avons eu de nombreux débats pour
essayer de rendre à peu près utilise
utile quelque chose qui était
incontrôlable
nous n'avons pas réussi nous n'avons pas
réussi et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
clairement il faut supprimer la il veut
c'est très clair on peut faire tout ce
qu'on veut
la mg n'est plus gérable et je vais vous
ainsi et je vais essayer de vous
expliquer pourquoi
d'abord c'est un système qui est très
difficile à gérer pour deux raisons il
est fondé sur l'immigration clandestine
par nature l'immigration clandestine est
très difficile à évaluer en nature
deuxième élément qui est terrible c'est
que la msp est un système où la loi
votée crédit mais ces crédits sont
entérinées en réalité utilisé par la
sécurité sociale et par conséquent le
manège entre la sécurité sociale et le
droit et la loi
ado et l'état le budget a donné lieu à
de nombreuses disqualifications en
réalité là et me depuis quelques années
et source d'abus considérable qui
viennent de partout premier je voulais
dire c'est qu'il ya incontestablement
pas autant qu'on le dit d'ailleurs un
abus qui vient de l'affluence des
immigrés clandestins
est-ce qu'ils sont attirés par les
assurances sociales est ce qu'ils sont
attirés par les prestations sociales
c'est beaucoup moins vrai qu'on ne le
dit mais c'est réel et en particulier
les procédures d'urgence qui sont
extrêmement coûteuses nous coûte
terriblement sur le plan budgétaire
premier élément deuxième élément il est
évident qu'à partir du moment où c'est
la sécurité sociale qui gère les formes
l'état il ya eu des abus qui sont des
avis médicaux et nous avons eu une très
très grosse
faire il ya quelques années du point de
vue financier avec les critères
hospitalier qui coûtait quand même la
bagatelle de 150 millions à au budget
alors qu'en réalité ce n'était pas du
tout des fonds à eveux mes défauts que
la sécurité sociale replacer sur les
conditions hospitalières
il y avait aussi des abus qui venait de
certaines professions médicales qui
permettait avec 20 euros à chaque
consultation à certains médecins de
faire des travaux qui étaient pas très
cher aux pharmaciens s'est fait des amis
multiples le véritable problème c'est
que c'est à lui successifs ont été
camouflés par l'état et à partir de là
la m e est devenu une machine qui dans
l'opinion publique est devenue
extrêmement perverses
d'abord parce que le système qui donnait
à chaque personne la possibilité de
payer de ne pas payer alors que les
français étaient soumis à contribution
était de plus en plus mal ressentie avec
la crise première les bandes
deuxième élément il est clair que la
dissimulation des crédits qui ont été
petit sont patents depuis une dizaine
d'années la dissimulation des crédits à
renforcer cette cette cabale en disant
en fait on nous chasse on nous cache la
réalité
j'ai donc été chargé plusieurs années de
suivre les finances de l'année mais je
peux vous dire que c'est quelque chose
en effet le chiffre de la mg n'est pas
du tout conforme à celui que nous votons
l'assemblée nationale et je dirais même
que le chiffre de l'aide prestations
sociales médicale des immigrés
clandestins n'a encore rien à voir avec
le chiffre probable de la m e il est
beaucoup plus fort d'abord lorsque nous
votons à l'assemblée nationale nous
votons sur un budget a minima et ne
pourra la loi rectificative nous
n'apprenons qu'au mois d'octobre qu'en
réalité ce budget a minima il a
considérablement complexe que nous
savions ce que je démontrais évidemment
chaque année aux directeurs de la santé
mais bien évidemment il vaut mieux voter
600 millions que d'entrée voter un
milliard or le système des lois
rectificatives pouce à la consommation
parce qu'évidemment toute personne se
dit on y aura la loi rectificative on
peut y aller et la sécu est en tête
premier élément deuxième élément on ne
comptabilise pas dans le budget
les emprunts qui ont été faits sur le
par exemple sur la sécurité sociale
l'état doit une centaine de millions à
la sécurité sociale qui n'est pas
déclarée dans le budget deuxième élément
troisième élément encore plus grave
c'est qu'il y à un certain nombre de
crédits qui ne sont pas budgétée et
depuis plusieurs années nous courons
après les crédits en question il ya deux
départements qui sont ruineux
sur le plan de l'aide aux clandestins
c'est la guyane et mayotte qui vont
d'ailleurs posé tôt ou tard le problème
du droit du sol pour peut-être le sujet
qu'on va aborder tout à l'heure la
guyane et mayotte ne sont pas que
mayotte n'est pas comptabilisé parce que
mayotte n'est pas encore un département
au sens plein du terme
après plusieurs années de demandes
d'inspection de recours
employant tous les moyens judiciaires et
juridiques qui sont les nôtres
moi j'ai valu à mayotte probablement à
150 millions d'euros la contribution aux
immigrés clandestins qui n'est pas dans
le budget m
il faut donc rajouter quant à la guyane
pour donner un deuxième exemple la
chambre régionale des comptes de guyane
a mis en évidence que il ne pouvait pas
les chiffres donnés par la guyane à la
sève ne pouvait pas être retenu comme
telle elle l'a démontré ministère de la
santé sans est foutue complètement je
n'arrive pas à connaître le budget nous
n'arrivons pas à connaître le budget de
d2 première clinique gynécologique
d'europe qui sont saint laurent du
maroni et l'hôpital public de mayotte
peut pas continuer comme ça c'est à dire
on peut pas continuer à voir une source
de capitaux cachés de camouflage
budgétaire donc malgré tous nos bons
efforts là et me c'est fini voilà
trouver un autre système